employment fraud tops the list of the
riskiest scams targeting consumers in
2018 first on CBS this morning a new
report by the Better Business Bureau
says job scams made up just over 9% of
the total Anna Werner shows us how one
man became a victim and is now paying
the price in a good morning good morning
and you know the Better Business Bureau
doesn't just look at how often a scam
happens now they look at how susceptible
you might be to a particular scam and
how much you could lose a Montana man
found out the answers to both those
questions and they weren't good brad
helding wanted some extra work so he
posted his resume on some job sites and
soon got an email from a company calling
itself Delta Xpress couriers we found
your resume and we think we would like
to talk to you about a position that
might fit what you're looking for the
job an offer to work from home as a
purchase clerk buying electronics in
large quantities than shipping them to
the company's clients mostly overseas
the company told him since Montana has
no sales tax they'd save money running
the purchases through him I would be
shopping locally or online for phones
computer parts laptops the job paid over
seventy two thousand dollars a year plus
bonuses it certainly sounded very
appealing to me at the time and helding
says he did his research checking the
company's website and Sacramento
location it all seemed you know upfront
to me so he filled out tax and
employment forms and when this offer
letter arrived he signed it the company
then sent him two thousand dollars so he
bought iPhones at this Best Buy and
shipped them off as instructed he says
for the next batch of purchases the
company told him to temporarily use his
own credit card but provided bank
account and routing numbers he could use
to reimburse himself for those expenses
it worked until he called his card
company a few weeks later this is well I
need to tell you that account is stolen
and you are not authorized to make
payments from that account and when he
called Delta Express he only got this
automated message
thank you for calling Delta Express
couriers can't leave us a message with
your name and telephone number and we
will return your calls during normal
business hours it turned out all the
transactions were fraudulent including
that original $2,000 payment now Brad
handling is out what he paid for the
electronics over thirty five thousand
dollars it was a horrible horrible
feeling
he's one of thousands of Americans who
fall for employment scams Better
Business Bureaus Melissa Trump our
scammers definitely use at home
opportunities because they know a lot of
people are looking for that opportunity
so in Brad scam do we know who did it I
don't believe we know who did it right
now
Adam Levin's company Cyber Scout has
been looking into heldens case which he
says shows indications of criminal
syndicates because they're laundering
money they have to find a way to launder
the money so they come up with all these
different scams in order to do it
effectively because they've got to end
the trail so they get him to buy thirty
thousand dollars worth of electronics
then they go and sell the thirty
thousand dollars of electronics yeah and
they've got clean money so the how the
money's clean it's been laundered money
that helding now owes I'm not a stupid
person I'm neither education have been
around the world and I thought my god
what have I done what have I fallen for
we found the real Delta Xpress couriers
went out of business several years back
work at home job scams are extremely
common and the BBB says you should be
very very careful about them especially
if the company contacts you as they did
in this case so he has no recourse in
order to get no recourse because his
credit card company American Express
told him you made the charges it's not
like somebody stole your card yeah and
made charges brother wipe them out he
made the charges and so now he's trying
to get a purchase a payment plan I could
see why he fell for it though if they
send you $2,000 and you cash and you
think okay this has got to be legit he
says I'm not a stupid person I see why
they sent a hook yeah that's exactly
what it was all fraud you to know you
Anna thank you Anna